Alice:怎么没杯子呢
Alice: Why are there no cups?
Alice:拿个碗吧
Alice: Let's use a bowl.
Alice:这个吗
Alice: This one?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 直接倒就
Shure: Just pour it directly.
Shure: 倒了一点醋
Shure: Poured a bit of vinegar.
Shure: 怎么样
Shure: How is it?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 评价一下吧
Shure: Give it a review.
Shure: 喝不惯是吧
Shure: Not used to drinking it, right?
Alice:啊太酸了
Alice: Ah, it's too sour.
Alice:感觉跟冲的还是不一样
Alice: It feels different from the brewed one.
Alice:比它好喝
Alice: This one tastes better.
Alice:但是你喜欢酸的吗
Alice: But do you like sour things?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 然后这种
Shure: And this kind...
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 他能喝出来一些其他的花果香
Shure: You can taste some other floral and fruity notes.
Alice:嗯确实有点后味
Alice: Yeah, it does have a bit of an aftertaste.
Katrina: 回龙关在哪
Katrina: Where is Huilongguan?
Shure: 回龙观对
Shure: Huilongguan, yes.
Katrina: 哦那离离那个西直门远吗
Katrina: Oh, is it far from Xizhimen?
Shure: 离沙河远
Shure: It's far from Shahe.
Alice:离西直门
Alice: From Xizhimen...
Alice:说远不远
Alice: Not too far.
Alice:说近不近得一个多小时一个
Alice: Not too close either, about more than an hour.
Shure: 不不到一个小时
Shure: No, not even an hour.
Alice:一个吧
Alice: About an hour.
Shure: 坐十三号线就就可以
Shure: Just take Line 13, that's it.
Katrina: 回龙关到西直门
Katrina: Huilongguan to Xizhimen...
Katrina: 八寨
Katrina: Eight stations.
Shure: 对 31分钟
Shure: Yes, 31 minutes.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yep.
Shure: 你看看
Shure: Look.
Alice:牛逼啊
Alice: Impressive.
Shure: LOCO我跟你讲
Shure: LOCO, I'm telling you.
Katrina: logo哈哈哈
Katrina: Logo, hahaha.
Alice:确实没办法我们这
Alice: Indeed, there's nothing we can do.
Katrina: 你们你们校区在哪啊
Katrina: Where is your campus?
Alice:我们只有一个校区在村
Alice: We only have one campus, in the village.
Shure: 中船是吗
Shure: Zhongchuan, right?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Shure: 中船在离这其实挺近
Shure: Zhongchuan is actually quite close to here.
Katrina: 在昌平啊
Katrina: In Changping.
Alice:在朝阳离这很近
Alice: In Chaoyang, very close to here.
Katrina: 哦哦哦中场我找
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh, I found the hotel in the middle.
Katrina: 我当时就定的中场附近的酒店
Katrina: I booked a hotel near the middle at that time.
Katrina: 去那个环球影城来着
Katrina: Went to Universal Studios.
Katrina: 然后然后在旁边麦当劳
Katrina: Then, then there was a McDonald's next to it.
Katrina: 晚上12点巨多人
Katrina: At midnight, there were tons of people.
Katrina: 全是学生
Katrina: All students.
Shure: 尝尝这个地道的老北京美食
Shure: Try some authentic old Beijing food.
Alice:那个是你们学校的吗
Shure: 对没错
Shure: Yes, that's right.
Alice:你们学校
Alice: Your school...
Alice:包子真有那么好吃
Alice: Are the buns really that good?
Shure: 不知道他能吃32个
Shure: I didn't know he could eat 32 of them.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 我也是是个那他
Shure: I was also, like...
Katrina: 他一个人吃32个
Katrina: He ate 32 by himself?
Shure: 我不知道他为什么点32个
Shure: I don't know why he ordered 32.
Lucia: 哎这个葡萄洗好了吗
Lucia: Hey, are these grapes washed?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice:因为如果是食堂的包子话
Alice: Because if the buns are from the canteen...
Alice:应该有那个什么补助之类的
Alice: There should be some kind of subsidy, right?
Shure: 反正就这么大的那种包子
Shure: Anyway, the buns were about this big.
Alice:什么馅啊
Alice: What filling?
Alice:有这么好吃
Alice: Are they really that good?
Katrina: 脱胶带可全
Katrina: The tape came off.
Shure: 牛肉馅还行吧
Shure: The beef filling was okay.
Shure: 我只能说我那天尝了一口
Shure: I can only say I had a bite that day.
Alice:你吃过吗
Alice: Have you tried it?
Shure: 就是凤凰包子味
Shure: Just tasted like Phoenix buns.
Shure: 没有什么特别的感觉
Shure: Didn't feel anything special.
Alice:你们最近是不是开了一个什么自创
Alice: Did you guys recently open some kind of creative shop?
Alice:那个什么自那个
Alice: Some kind of... that...
Alice:那个文创店
Alice: That cultural shop.
Alice:嗯刷到了
Alice: Yeah, I saw it online.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 那事都顶了热搜第二了天
Alice:撤的也挺快
Alice: It got taken down pretty fast.
Alice:就是一个很很很很会
Alice: It was like, very, very, very...
Alice:他们学校的
Alice: From their school
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Alice:你们你们不知道吗不知道
Alice: You guys didn't know? Really didn't know?
Lucia: 不知道我最近没怎么刷
Lucia: No idea, I haven't been checking lately
Lucia: 这是什么
Lucia: What's this about?
Alice:就文娱知
Alice: Just entertainment news
Alice:识吧不对
Alice: Or gossip, wait no
Alice:不是不是
Alice: No, no
Alice:知识文娱八卦之类的
Alice: Knowledge, entertainment, gossip, stuff like that
Lucia: 最近几天太忙了都没有刷这些软件
Lucia: I've been too busy these past few days to check those apps
Shure: 不是上上周的事
Shure: Wasn't it from the week before last?
Shure: 就来之前的事应该是
Shure: Should be before we came here
Lucia: ah OK
Lucia: Ah, OK
Alice:你之后要去哪读书啊
Alice: Where are you planning to study next?
Katrina: 我去南京
Katrina: I'm going to Nanjing
Katrina: 我去东南那边
Katrina: To Southeast University over there
Shure: 哎有书读啊真好
Shure: Ah, so nice to have school to attend
Lucia: 哦原来这是肥肠
Lucia: Oh, so this is pork intestine
Lucia: 帮我解锁一下
Lucia: Help me unlock
Lucia: 一种新食物
Lucia: A new food
Katrina: 拿瓦分是吗
Katrina: Should we share it?
Shure: 拿碗分吧
Shure: Let's divide it into bowls
Shure: 别一下又打了啊
Shure: Don't hit it all at once
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you
Katrina: 我爸是
Katrina: My dad is
Shure: 这是谁谁的电脑
Shure: Whose computer is this?
Shure: 收一下吧
Shure: Put it away
Shure: 谁的
Shure: Whose is it?
Shure: 啊他闪的电脑是吗
Shure: Ah, is it his computer?
Shure: 昨天不会来打游戏来了吧哈哈哈
Shure: Didn't he come here yesterday just to play games? Haha
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes
Jake:打完游戏抢红包贼开心
Jake: Finished playing games and was so happy grabbing red envelopes
Shure: 你在这打游戏来着是吗
Shure: You were playing games here, right?
Shure: 收下收下
Shure: Put it away
Lucia: 23
Lucia: 哎我今天早上拿上来一包好像
Lucia: Ah, I think I brought up a pack this morning
Jake:他这有貔貅吗
Jake: Does he have a Pixiu?
Shure: 他这个是
Shure: Is this his
Lucia: 哎没有吗
Lucia: Hey, is it not here?
Lucia: 那我再拿一把
Lucia: Then I'll get another one.
Jake:不是就是外外
Jake: No, it's just outside.
Shure: kitanweps
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Jake:这里还有一些遗留溪秀
Jake: There are still some leftovers here.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:你看
Jake: Look.
Jake:凑一凑长一长
Jake: Gather them and make it longer.
Shure: 那筷子
Shure: The chopsticks.
Shure: 能使吗
Shure: Can we use them?
Shure: 还要使刷一下
Shure: Do we need to wash them first?
Tasha: 稍微冲一下吧
Tasha: Just rinse them a bit.
Alice:哪个啊
Alice: Which one?
Alice:这是
Alice: This one?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Shure: 最多赚了快1万
Shure: Made almost 10 thousand at most.
Shure: 最后一分也没赚
Shure: Didn't make a single cent in the end.
Jake:为什么
Jake: Why?
Shure: 为什么因为这些东西太多了
Shure: Why? Because there was too much stuff.
Shure: 呃涨幅太大了
Shure: Uh, the price increase was too big.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:我们钱币即将发售
Jake: Our currency is about to be released.
Jake:我们货币即将发售
Shure: 我们的币
Shure: Our currency.
Shure: 子上链了家人们
Shure: It's on the blockchain, everyone.
Jake:大家大家忘掉这件事情
Jake: Everyone, forget about this.
Jake:10年之后再想起来
Jake: Think about it again in 10 years.
Shure: 然后就发现自己富了是吗
Shure: And then realize you're rich, right?
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Jake:财务自由职业自由
Jake: Financial freedom, career freedom.
Shure: 真的会吗杨老板
Shure: Will it really happen, Jake?
Tasha: 往我的账户里面先充50个50个
Tasha: Put 50 of them into my account first.
Jake:总共150个
Jake: A total of 150.
Shure: 什么时候能让我实现财富自由呢
Shure: When can I achieve financial freedom?
Alice:找个兜塞他
Alice: Put it in a pocket.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake:那就得
Jake: Well, that depends.
Alice:快的话今晚就可以
Alice: If you're lucky, tonight.
Jake:你
Jake: You...
Jake:哈哈哈这怎么做的这个哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, how did you make this? Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这已经开始画饼了是吧
Lucia: Hahaha, are you starting to paint a picture?
Shure: 今天晚上
Shure: Tonight...
Shure: 你先选一个
Shure: You choose one first.
Tasha: 少个凳子
Tasha: Missing a chair.
Alice:哼哼
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha: 再来个凳子
Tasha: Let's get another chair.
Tasha: 我
Tasha: I...
Lucia: 我还少一个凳子
Lucia: I'm still missing a chair.
Alice:可以给你一个筷子吗
Alice: Can I get you a pair of chopsticks?
Jake:好吃吗火烧
Jake: Is the roasted bun tasty?
Jake:好吃
Jake: Tasty.
Lucia: 我来分发一下
Lucia: Let me distribute these.
Jake:驴肉对
Jake: Donkey meat, right.
Jake:这就是驴肉
Jake: This is donkey meat.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mmm.
Tasha: 要个这个就行了
Tasha: This one is fine.
Tasha: 我不要筷子了
Tasha: I don't need chopsticks.
Lucia: 啊那那给给健康好了
Lucia: Ah, then give it to Ken.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 那这筷子就放这
Lucia: Then, I'll put the chopsticks here.
Jake:我我还有
Jake: I still have.
Alice:把这个弄开吧
Alice: Let’s open this up.
Jake:我还有一套餐具
Jake: I still have a set of utensils.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:是吗这是我的啊
Jake: Really? This is mine.
Tasha: 这这还有筷子呢
Tasha: There are still chopsticks here.
Alice:这这还有筷子吗
Alice: Are there still chopsticks?
Lucia: 啊刚刚不是给你了一套
Lucia: Ah, didn't I just give you a set?
Alice:这里面给的有
Alice: There are some inside.
Jake:这是啊这不是我
Jake: This one, it's not mine.
Lucia: 笑死了我刚还以为你有两个
Lucia: I'm dying of laughter. I thought you had two sets.
Jake:我有两个人
Jake: I have two people.
Lucia: 人哈哈哈
Lucia: People, haha.
Shure: 卤煮火烧
Shure: Braised bun.
Tasha: 你要吃这个是吗
Tasha: You want to eat this, right?
Jake:呃我也吃火烧
Jake: Uh, I'll have a roasted bun too.
Jake:今晚吃什么
Jake: What’s for dinner tonight?
Jake:麦麦当劳汉堡是吧
Jake: McDonald's burger, right?
Tasha: 嘿嘿
Tasha: Hehe
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Lucia: 你们这边有了吗
Lucia: Do you have it over there?
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay
Jake:我们吃过麦当劳汉堡吗
Jake: Have we eaten McDonald's burgers?
Alice:你要吗
Alice: Do you want it?
Jake:还肯德基
Jake: Or KFC?
Jake:第一天肯德基是吧
Jake: First day was KFC, right?
Lucia: 那我吃了
Lucia: Then I'll have it
Shure: 要加点蒜泥吗
Shure: Want to add some garlic paste?
Lucia: 有吗
Lucia: Do we have it?
Shure: 来是这里的
Shure: It's over here
Shure: 帮忙拿一个蒜泥
Shure: Help me get some garlic paste
Shure: 首先倒倒倒里了
Shure: First, pour it in here
Tasha: 啊我只是想要一个娃哈哈
Tasha: Ah, I just wanted a Wahaha drink
Jake:那你娃哈那
Jake: Then have your Wahaha
Shure: 倒倒这边我给你
Shure: Pour it over here, I'll give it to you
Jake:那你待着吧
Jake: Then stay put
Jake:你待着
Jake: Stay put
Lucia: 我给你开了一瓶
Lucia: I opened a bottle for you
Tasha: 还有谁要
Tasha: Anyone else want one?
Lucia: 娃哈哈你还没喝呢
Lucia: You haven't even drunk your Wahaha
Jake:是是是我想是的
Jake: Yes, yes, I think so
Shure: 这韭菜花先不用
Shure: Don't need the chive flower sauce yet
Tasha: 7个人
Tasha: 7 people
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Alice:还有个俘虏
Alice: And a prisoner
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Hmm hmm
Alice:哎
Alice: Eh
Shure: 他早期的食物
Shure: His early food
Shure: 他早期的时候不是已经这个样吗
Shure: Wasn't his early food like this?
Alice:这个要吗？
Alice: Do you want this?
Alice:哎
Alice: Eh
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know
Shure: 呃他啥不吃
Shure: Uh, what doesn't he eat?
Lucia: 他们那有
Lucia: They have it
Lucia: 有一碗那就不加
Lucia: If there's a bowl, then don't add it
Alice:辣椒油
Alice: Chili oil
Shure: 辣椒油可以整喽
Shure: You can add chili oil
Lucia: 这是啥呀哦
Lucia: What is this, oh
Alice:给
Alice: Here you go.
Alice:娃哈哈吗修硕
Alice: Wahaha, Shure?
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Shure: ad钙是吗
Shure: AD Calcium, right?
Shure: 可以来一瓶
Shure: I'll take a bottle.
其他人：是娃哈哈矿泉水吗
Others: Is it Wahaha mineral water?
Shure: 有北冰洋吗
Shure: Do you have Arctic Ocean?
Alice:楼下有
Alice: There's some downstairs.
Shure: 我要要北冰洋
Shure: I want Arctic Ocean.
Shure: 谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Jake:这卤乳是不是得有勺啊
Jake: Does this marinated tofu need a spoon?
其他人：不用了
Others: No need.
Jake:不用了
Jake: No need.
Alice:要有勺也可以
Alice: You can use a spoon if you want.
Jake:啊有勺
Jake: Ah, a spoon.
Jake:哦原来有勺可以
Jake: Oh, so we can use a spoon.
Alice:有
Alice: Yes.
Shure: 他火上好像都在底下
Shure: It seems everything is at the bottom.
Jake:比什么
Jake: Compared to what?
Jake:比啥玩意好吃
Jake: Compared to what is it better?
Jake:卤煮
Jake: Marinated pork.
Shure: 招信他的杨老板
Shure: Trust him, Jake.
Alice:有这些料你要吗
Alice: Do you want these seasonings?
Shure: 他不专业
Shure: He's not professional.
Shure: 我怎么插
Shure: How do I insert this?
Shure: 插不进去啊
Shure: I can't insert it.
Alice:韭哎呦
Alice:韭花然后
Alice:蒜
Alice: Garlic.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Alice:嗯辣椒油
Alice: Yes, chili oil.
Alice:应该还有个腐乳
Alice: There should be fermented tofu.
Lucia: 这是什么 肺子吗
Lucia: What is this, lungs?
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Jake:你为什么不吃卤猪
Jake: Why don't you eat marinated pork?
Jake:好丑呀好丑
Jake: It's so ugly, so ugly.
Lucia: 我吃到血味了
Lucia: I can taste the blood.
Jake:这丑吗
Jake: Is this ugly?
Tasha: 可他都是大肠小肠大脑小脑的感觉
Tasha: But it all feels like large intestine, small intestine, brain, and cerebellum.
其他人：瞧不起谁呢
Others: Who are you looking down on?
其他人：谁也没有个东西
Others: No one has anything.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 那你为什么把别人吃下肚
Tasha: Then why did you eat someone else?
Jake:它有3种是吧大肠肝
Jake: It has three types, right? Large intestine, liver...
Alice:这个是肺
Alice: This is lung.
Jake:是肺肺
Jake: Yeah, lung, lung.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:应该在底下
Alice: It should be at the bottom.
Tasha: 火烧是什么
Tasha: What is "huoshao"?
Tasha: 是哪个部位啊
Tasha: Which part is it?
Jake:面啊
Jake: It's bread.
Lucia: 我也想问
Lucia: I also want to ask.
Lucia: 火烧是哪个部位
Lucia: Which part is "huoshao"?
Shure: 对这面块块就是火烧
Shure: Yes, this bread piece is "huoshao".
Tasha: 啊是什么
Tasha: What is it?
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This.
Jake:面
Jake: Bread.
Jake:就驴肉火烧
Jake: It's just donkey meat "huoshao".
Jake:就是驴肉和火烧
Jake: It's donkey meat and "huoshao".
Jake:就是驴肉火烧
Jake: It's donkey meat "huoshao".
Lucia: 是这样的吗
Lucia: Is it like this?
Jake:煎驴肉就是那个东西
Jake: Fried donkey meat is that thing.
Jake:是吧你看
Jake: Right, look.
Shure: 面面面饼饼
Shure: Bread, bread, bread.
Tasha: 这个就是
Tasha: This is it.
Alice:这个就是火烧
Alice: This is "huoshao".
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:火烧用火烧出来的面嗯
Alice: "Huoshao" is bread baked with fire.
Jake:对用火烧出来的面
Jake: Yes, bread baked with fire.
Lucia: 好神奇啊
Lucia: So amazing.
Lucia: 出感叹
Lucia: Exclaims.
Jake:多半是没吃过牛肉火烧
Jake: Most of you haven't had beef "huoshao".
Shure: 我有次吃河北人带来的卤火烧
Shure: One time, I had braised "huoshao" brought by a guy from Hebei.
Shure: 真的是真他妈好吃
Shure: It was really f**king delicious.
Jake:怎么带过来的就
Jake: How did he bring it?
Shure: 就他带过来
Shure: He just brought it.
Shure: 就是冷的
Shure: It was cold.
Shure: 都很好吃我去
Shure: It was all delicious, oh my god.
Jake:这3个东西
Jake: These three things.
Jake:你们用了吗
Jake: Did you use them?
Shure: 用了把蒜汁和那个辣椒油浇了就行
Shure: Just pour some garlic juice and chili oil on it, and it's done.
Jake:用了
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 那个韭菜花一般不加
Shure: Usually, we don't add chive flowers.
Shure: low口
Shure: Low-key.
Shure: 必须的
Shure: Definitely.
Jake:吃啥呀腐乳
Jake: What are we eating, fermented tofu?
Alice:腐乳
Alice: Fermented tofu.
Jake:腐乳加吗
Jake: Do we add fermented tofu?
Shure: 腐竹不加
Shure: No, we don't add dried tofu.
Jake:不加好
Jake: Okay, no need to add it.
Shure: 也可以尝试
Shure: You can try it though.
Shure: 但我没加过
Shure: But I've never added it.
Shure: 我不够local
Shure: I'm not local enough.
Jake:咱要不顺势把豆汁撒在床上
Jake: How about we just spill the soy milk on the bed?
Lucia: 我们买豆汁了吗
Lucia: Did we buy soy milk?
Tasha: 买了一瓶吧
Tasha: We bought a bottle, right?
Alice:不是买了一瓶吗
Alice: Didn't we buy a bottle?
Lucia: 在哪呢走来
Lucia: Where is it then?
Jake:先说要吃完吗
Jake: First, are we going to finish it?
Jake:别的吃不了
Jake: We can't eat anything else.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：我吃不了一点
Others: I can't eat any more.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 吃饱了再喝那个不是危险性更大吗
Lucia: Isn't it more dangerous to drink that after being full?
Lucia: 哈哈哈说这么直白干什么
Lucia: Haha, why are you being so blunt?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Tasha: 已经要吐了
Tasha: I'm already about to throw up.
Shure: 我不吃
Shure: I'm not eating it.
Shure: 我喝过
Shure: I've drunk it before.
Lucia: 我没吃过
Lucia: I've never had it.
其他人 ：我怕吃完咱们又扩一杯了
Others: I'm afraid we'll have to drink another cup after eating it.
Jake:为啥啊
Jake: Why?
其他人 ：下午直接走了
Others: We'll leave directly in the afternoon.
Tasha: 那次在中国买了一一一袋
Tasha: That time, we bought a bag in China.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:接头一单
Jake: First order.
Shure: 这个活
Shure: This task.
Tasha: 我们同学三个人去买了一罐
Tasha: Three of our classmates went to buy a can.
Shure: 给给别人做
Shure: Make it for someone else.
Tasha: 当时说是什么味来着
Tasha: What did you say it tasted like back then?
Tasha: 反正中午吃的全部都吐了
Tasha: Anyway, I threw up everything I ate at noon.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 听起来好危险
Lucia: That sounds dangerous.
其他人：这个
Others: This...
其他人：真的会在几十年后让我们财富自由吗
Others: Will this really make us financially free in decades?
Jake:这个怎么怎么炒啊
Jake: How do we trade this?
Shure: 你相你相信30年后财务自由
Shure: Do you believe you'll be financially free in 30 years?
Shure: 不相信你能活到30年
Shure: I don't believe you'll live 30 years.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 我应该差不多吧
Shure: I think I'll make it.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 50岁我还活不到吗
Shure: I can't make it to 50 years old?
Shure: 那差不多
Shure: That's about right.
Lucia: 而且还要考虑通货膨胀因素
Lucia: And we have to consider inflation too.
Shure: 金币很珍惜
Shure: Gold coins are rare.
Shure: 就是只有150个
Shure: There are only 150 of them.
其他人：到时候要是马斯克看上了马斯克
Others: If Musk likes it in the future...
其他人：再配上发一句话
Others: And says something about it...
Tasha: 一钩币
Tasha: One coin.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
其他人：对我好有一天
Others: Exactly, one day...
Lucia: 那就得
Lucia: Then...
Lucia: 这个监制的任务就得交给杨老板了
Lucia: Jake has to take on the producer's role.
Tasha: 真的会发行150个虚拟币吗
Tasha: Will 150 virtual coins really be issued?
Shure: 我跟你说
Shure: Let me tell you...
Shure: 有一天就是大一的时候
Shure: One day, when I was a freshman...
Jake:是发150个币
Jake: They will issue 150 coins.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 大一的时候张晨他晚上睡得很晚
Shure: When I was a freshman, Zhang Chen stayed up very late.
Jake:真的吗
Jake: Really?
Tasha: 真的吗
Shure: 然后张晨在刷推特
Shure: And Zhang Chen was browsing Twitter.
Shure: 看见了马斯克说屎逼
Shure: He saw Musk say something like 'crap'.
Shure: 你知道那个逼吗
Shure: You know what that word means, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 骂的张晨当时就刷到了
Shure: Zhang Chen saw it right at that moment.
Shure: 其实其实我没睡
Shure: Actually, I wasn't asleep.
Shure: 但是他以为我睡
Shure: But he thought I was.
Shure: 他没跟我说那个时候在
Shure: He didn't tell me about that time.
Shure: 那个时候在地下都没那
Shure: At that time, it wasn't on the big exchange.
Shure: 个使劲都没上大交易所
Shure: He didn't put much effort into it, didn't get on the big exchange.
Shure: 马上他直接下了个小小交易所
Shure: Then he immediately went to a small exchange.
Shure: 赶快买了2,000的
Shure: Quickly bought 2,000 worth.
Shure: 使劲交钱就变8,000
Shure: And it turned into 8,000 really fast.
其他人：中
Others: Right.
其他人 ：赚钱不给兄弟赚
Others: Making money but not sharing with brothers.
Alice: ：哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 我之前还跟张成一直在宿舍挖李天坊
Shure: I used to dig Li Tianfang in the dorm with Zhang Cheng.
Jake:你
Jake: You...
Shure: 挖了个小一圈
Shure: Dug up a small circle.
Shure: 把我咸海王挖起来
Shure: Dug up my salted sea king.
Shure: 我去维修的时候
Shure: When I was doing repairs,
Shure: 然后问你这鞋上有两道黑伤
Shure: I asked, why are there two black marks on your shoes?
Jake:有什么卡吗
Jake: Do you have any cards?
Shure: 303060 就
Shure: 303060, just...
Jake:就就我给你了哈哈
Jake: I gave you that one, haha.
Shure: 不不不
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 这能咋整
Shure: What can I do?
Shure: 大意思就拿我比
Shure: I was just comparing.
Shure: 笔记本
Shure: Laptop.
Shure: 不 2060
Shure: No, 2060.
Shure:  拆没有拆
Shure: Didn't take it apart.
其他人：没有没有带笔记本没有
Others: Didn't bring the laptop, no.
Shure: 然后这个修电脑感觉很不可思议的说
Shure: And then the computer repair guy found it unbelievable,
Shure: 我说我就是玩游戏
Shure: I said I just play games.
Shure: 打英雄联盟打多了
Shure: Play a lot of League of Legends.
其他人：打英雄联盟打不过对
Others: Can't win at League of Legends, right.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 那你们宿舍电不会耗很快吗
Lucia: Doesn't your dorm use up electricity quickly?
Shure: 对那两个人就是我跟张二婶付电费
Shure: Yeah, the two of us, me and Zhang Ershen, paid the electricity bill.
Shure: 因为那段时间的
Shure: Because during that time,
Shure: 那段时间低
Shure: During that time,
Shure: 太值钱了
Shure: It was really valuable.
Shure: 电费已经完全靠不了
Shure: The electricity bill couldn't keep up at all.
Shure: 等等就大概是三三月份挖了吧
Shure: Around March, we started digging.
Shure: 五月份国家就出台了个政策
Shure: In May, the government introduced a policy
Shure: 然后就腰斩
Shure: And then it got halved.
Shure: 对不起对不起
Shure: Sorry, sorry.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 我知道虚拟货币极其不稳定
Shure: I know that virtual currency is extremely unstable.
Shure: 国家就应该支持
Shure: The government should support it.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 这都是泡沫以及激烈打击
Shure: It's all just a bubble and intense crackdown.
其他人：十二点二十一分
Others: It's twelve twenty-one.
Shure:  ：然后标签打成危险颜色
Shure: Then tag it with a warning color.
Jake:就是网管
Jake: It's the network admin.
Jake:基本上就干这个
Jake: Basically, just doing this.
Jake:就是计个时间
Jake: Just keeping time.
Jake:哈哈哈要举报
Jake: Hahaha, need to report.
Shure: 本来身边好多那种
Shure: There were a lot of those cases around.
Shure: 不知道你们记不记得那个天津那个人
Shure: Don't know if you remember that guy from Tianjin.
Shure: 也没酒驾也没毒驾
Shure: Neither drunk driving nor drug driving.
Shure: 就搁那装人
Shure: Just pretending to be someone.
Shure: 那种事件
Shure: Those kinds of incidents.
Shure: 打桥然后装人
Shure: Pretending to be someone on the bridge.
Shure: 感觉全是超逼超多
Shure: Felt like there were too many.
Lucia: 决定到这边来加一个
Lucia: Decided to add one over here.
Lucia: 还挺好吃的嗯
Lucia: It's quite tasty, yeah.
Lucia: 对没吃过
Lucia: Yeah, haven't tried it before.
Lucia: 肥肠我吃过
Lucia: I've had pork intestines.
Lucia: 放在面里当浇头的那种
Lucia: As a topping in noodles.
Alice:那你可能也会吃炒肝
Alice: Then you might also like stir-fried liver.
Lucia: 说北京的那种炒肝吗
Lucia: You mean the Beijing style?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 啊我不喜欢那个
Lucia: Ah, I don't like that.
Lucia: 特别咸我觉得
Lucia: It's too salty, I think.
Alice:你不喜欢那个
Alice: You don't like it?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:特别咸嗯
Alice: Too salty, huh?
Lucia: 是不是我去的地方不对呀
Lucia: Maybe I went to the wrong place.
Lucia: 我觉得特别咸
Lucia: I think it's too salty.
Alice:可能是炒肝还没这个咸呢
Alice: Maybe the stir-fried liver isn't as salty as this.
Alice:就比这个会淡一点点
Alice: It's a bit lighter than this.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Lucia: 下次再试试
Lucia: Let's try again next time
Alice:但感觉炒干糊嘴
Alice: But it feels dry and gritty
Lucia: 对它是一种黏糊糊的
Lucia: Yeah, it's kind of sticky
Lucia: 像放了藕粉一样的感觉
Lucia: It feels like it has lotus root starch in it
Alice:感觉是藕粉一样的感觉
Alice: It feels like lotus root starch
Alice:感觉藕粉的那种清气
Alice: It has that clear, light feeling of lotus root starch
Lucia: 嗯对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, exactly
Alice:黏糊吧唧
Alice: Sticky and gooey
Jake:是什么呀辣椒
Jake: What's that? Chili?
Alice:辣椒油
Alice: Chili oil
Alice:韭花酱
Alice: Chive flower sauce
Alice:咸
Alice: Salty
Jake:那我多蘸多加点汤是吧
Jake: Then I should dip more and add some broth, right?
Alice:你直接倒吧
Alice: Just pour it directly
Alice:我想吃那个
Alice: I want to eat that
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks
Alice:这个吗
Alice: This one?
Alice:来一个
Alice: Give me one
Alice:呦
Alice: Oh
Tasha: 多米诺骨牌
Tasha: Dominoes
Jake:你这吸管咬得可以
Jake: You've really bitten that straw
Jake:他这吸管
Jake: His straw
Tasha: 没有跟我一样
Tasha: Not as much as mine
Jake:好像没有
Jake: Seems like it
Lucia: 我一般都是喝完了才有
Lucia: I usually only do that after finishing my drink
Jake:咬的很有艺术感
Jake: Your biting is artistic
Tasha: 这是一种领地意识
Tasha: It's a kind of territorial instinct
Tasha: 导致没有第二个人
Tasha: That prevents others
Tasha: 想喝我的饮料
Tasha: From wanting to drink my beverage
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:你会喝羊杂汤吗
Alice: Do you drink lamb offal soup?
Lucia: 我喝过
Lucia: I've had it
Alice:喜欢吗
Alice: Do you like it?
Lucia: 取决于他做的好不好
Lucia: Depends on how well it's made
Jake:喝什么哦
Jake: What are you drinking?
Lucia: 羊杂汤我感觉有的做的还确实还行
Lucia: Lamb offal soup, some are actually quite good
Alice:羊杂汤
Alice: Lamb offal soup
Lucia: 有的做的不好吃有点腥
Lucia: Some are not well-made and taste a bit gamey
Jake:泡馍用的吗
Jake: Is it for dipping bread?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Lucia: 其实像这里面这个肺我就不是特喜欢
Lucia: Actually, I don't really like the lung in this dish.
Lucia: 因为我刚吃了一块饭
Lucia: Because I just had a bite of rice.
Lucia: 他有雪块味
Lucia: It has a bloody taste.
Lucia: 我就没再吃了
Lucia: So I didn't eat it anymore.
Lucia: 但是其他的都很好吃
Lucia: But everything else is really delicious.
Alice:心好吃啊
Alice: The heart is tasty.
Lucia: 对心好吃
Lucia: 心没有味道
Lucia: 而且很有嚼劲
Lucia: And it's very tender.
Alice:比较韧
Alice: It's quite chewy.
Jake:咱这豆汁什么时候喝呀
Jake: When are we drinking the fermented bean juice?
Jake:明天后天谁买的
Jake: Who bought it for tomorrow or the day after?
其他人：我不知道
Others: I don't know.
Jake:哈哈哈这是你吗
Jake: Haha, is it you?
Shure: 反正谁买谁喝啊
Shure: Whoever bought it, drinks it.
Alice:谁买谁可以指定喝
Alice: Whoever bought it can designate who drinks it.
Tasha: 谁买的
Tasha: Who bought it?
Jake:谁花钱谁喝酒
Jake: Whoever paid, drinks.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 谁指定喝可爱酒
Lucia: Whoever designates drinks cute wine.
Jake:这个可以
Jake: That works.
Jake:你开了吗
Jake: Did you open it?
Jake:好好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 超市里这种豆汁
Lucia: In the supermarket, this kind of fermented bean juice
Lucia: 会不会做一些口味上的改良啊
Lucia: Do they make any flavor improvements?
Lucia: 要不然话不就没人买吗
Lucia: Otherwise, no one would buy it.
Tasha: 对啊肯定是这样子
Tasha: Yeah, definitely.
Lucia: 哇肚子疼
Lucia: Wow, my stomach hurts.
Shure: hello
Shure: Hello.
Alice:后面thank you
Alice: Thank you in the back.
Alice:thank you
Alice: Thank you.
Alice:这个应该用的死面吧
Alice: This should be made with unleavened dough, right?
Tasha: 这个什么东西
Tasha: What is this?
Alice:火烧
Alice: It's a baked cake.
Tasha: 应该是吧
Tasha: It should be.
Tasha: 死面就会比较硬
Tasha: Unleavened dough makes it harder.
Alice:嗯    不宣
Alice: Hmm, not soft.
Tasha: 我发现北方的馒头都不宣
Tasha: I noticed that northern mantou (steamed buns) are not soft.
Tasha: 就是特别硬的那种
Tasha: It's really hard, you know?
Alice:我们家做馒头就老用死面
Alice: At our home, we always use dead dough to make steamed buns.
Alice:我就不爱吃馒头
Alice: I just don't like steamed buns.
Tasha: 那我爱吃活面馒头
Tasha: Well, I love buns made with active dough.
Alice:其实也不是死的
Alice: Actually, it's not really dead.
Alice:有发酵但是比较梆梆硬比较实
Jake:哎这怎么开
Jake: Hey, how do you open this?
Jake:这是要干啥
Jake: What is this for?
其他人：不是我开的
Others: I didn't open it.
Jake:遥控器在哪火
Jake: Where's the remote control?
Lucia: 我记得还有一个鹅是怎么弄的来着
Lucia: I remember there was something about a goose, how did that work again?
Lucia: 是不是很好玩
Lucia: Isn't it fun?
Lucia: 还有这个这个
Lucia: And also this, this.
Lucia: AI你学会了吗
Lucia: AI, have you learned it?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Jake:哎这个像鸽子
Jake: Hey, this looks like a pigeon.
Katrina: 哎快断气了
Katrina: Hey, it's almost out of breath.
Lucia: 这个是大雁吗
Lucia: Is this a wild goose?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Jake:这是两只手
Jake: These are two hands.
Jake:哈哈哈这啥呀这是你
Jake: Hahaha, what is this, you?
Tasha: 哈哈你好AI啊哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha, you are so AI, hahaha.
Alice:手怎么弄啊
Alice: How do you do the hands?
Lucia: 不会哎有点像你说那种会吐吐吐
Lucia: I can't do it, it's a bit like what you said, it goes "toot toot toot."
Lucia: 那个什么呢
Lucia: What is that thing?
Jake:鸵鸟
Jake: Ostrich.
Jake:孔雀
Jake: Peacock.
Alice:哎 呀
Alice: Oh, yeah.
Tasha: 这像不像鹿
Tasha: Doesn't it look like a deer?
Lucia: 哎像的像的
Lucia: Yeah, it does, it does.
Alice:像
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:鸡冠头
Jake: Rooster comb.
Lucia: 为什么咱俩同一个手势
Lucia: Why do we have the same gesture?
Lucia: 你就是鹿而我是孔雀哈哈哈
Lucia: You're the deer, and I'm the peacock, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我记得我以前还会弄
Lucia: I remember I used to be able to do it.
Alice:眼珠会动哎好看
Alice: The eyes can move, it's beautiful.
Lucia: 哎好看
Lucia: Yeah, it's beautiful.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Lucia: 这猫哦
Lucia: This cat, oh.
Tasha: 石头
Tasha: Rock.
Alice:哎正在思考人类为什么要
Alice: Hmm, I'm thinking about why humans...
Alice:（歌声）咔吡 吧啦
Alice: (singing) Kapibara
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Ah ah
Alice:北京野生动物园
Alice: Beijing Wildlife Park
Alice:不是有那个卡皮巴拉吗
Alice: Don't they have capybaras there?
Alice:好多人去跟他合影
Alice: So many people take pictures with them
Alice:就拿个水果啥顶在他的头上
Alice: They put some fruit on its head
Alice:反正他也不动
Alice: And it doesn't move anyway
Alice:就是活也可以
Alice: Alive is okay too
Alice:不死
Alice: Not dead
Alice:不活也行
Alice:呵呵呵呵
Alice: Hehehe
Alice:活着也行
Alice: Alive is fine
Alice:死了也行
Alice: Dead is fine too
Alice:随便你就你这种精神状态
Alice: Whatever, with your kind of spirit
Lucia: 领先人类100年
Lucia: 100 years ahead of humans
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm
Jake:放个榴莲在头上
Jake: Put a durian on its head
Alice:哈哈哈顶橘子就橘子上面再放橘
Alice: Haha, put an orange, then another orange on top
Alice:橘子就像顶杂技一样
Alice: Like it's performing a balancing act
Alice:就不不动不管
Alice: It doesn't move, doesn't care
Alice:淡淡的死亡感
Alice: A faint sense of death
Alice:活着也行不活也行随便你
Alice: Alive is fine, not alive is fine, whatever
Alice:下午什么安排
Alice: What's the plan for the afternoon?
Alice:买东西
Alice: Shopping
Alice:估计快递也快到
Alice: The package should be arriving soon
Jake:拆快递
Jake: Unbox the package
Jake:你们拆快递
Jake: You guys unbox the package
Lucia: 然后布置
Lucia: Then arrange things
Jake:你们
Jake: You guys
Lucia: 然后收拾
Lucia: Then tidy up
Alice:他该布置了
Alice: He should arrange things
Jake:那个问答
Jake: The Q&A session
Shure: 那个问答
Shure: The Q&A session
Alice:还要收拾
Alice: And tidy up
Jake:问答的话GPT得干活啊
Jake: For the Q&A, GPT has to work
Lucia: PPT出完我们来检查一下吧
Lucia: Let's check the PPT after it's done
Lucia: 要不然他胡说八道
Lucia: Otherwise, it might be nonsense
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah
Jake:每天都让他有一个胡说八道的机会
Jake: Give it a chance to talk nonsense every day
Lucia: 每天都
Lucia: Every day
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yeah, just like that
Alice:所以还是不知道为什么
Alice: So still don't know why
Alice:那个什么一多少来着
Alice: What's that number again
Jake:132132 是回文数
Jake: 132132 is a palindrome
Alice:132132是回文数
Alice: 132132 is a palindrome
Alice:还有那个为什么代表3月21
Alice: And why does it represent March 21?
Jake:也没整明白
Jake: Still not clear
Lucia: 带
Lucia: With
Alice:为什么能用
Alice: Why can it be used
Alice:16 多少来着代表
Alice: 16 something represents
Jake:对这真是太离谱了这个
Jake: Yeah, it's really absurd
Alice:161还是啥 161吧
Alice: 161 or something, 161 right?
Lucia: 啊好像是
Lucia: Ah, seems like it
Alice:为什么呢
Alice: Why though?
Jake:是这么说的
Jake: That's what they said
Jake:他是说
Jake: He said
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Katrina: 好还是这么说
Katrina: Okay, let's say it like that
Jake:他是这么说的
Jake: That's what he said
Jake:161 这个数字代表国际植树节3月21号
Jake: 161 represents International Tree Planting Day on March 21
Jake:尽管他与世界第九日不是同一天哈
Jake: Even though it's not on the same day as World Earth Day
Alice:哈哈哈那我是不是还能代表328
Alice: Hahaha, then can I represent 328?
Alice:尽管他们不是同一个数字
Alice: Even though they are not the same number
Jake:哈哈是
Jake: Haha, yes
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Alice:哈哈是
Alice: Haha, yes
Jake:是这么回事哈哈哈
Jake: That's how it is, hahaha
Alice:是同一个
Alice: It's the same
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No
Lucia: 他哪怕把那个3月21除以2我都能接受
Lucia: Even if they divided March 21 by 2, I could accept that
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Lucia: 他给了一个什么奇怪的东西
Lucia: They gave some weird thing
Jake:139 这个数字
Jake: The number 139
Jake:象征着地球大气中主要气体的数量
Jake: Symbolizes the number of main gases in Earth's atmosphere
Lucia: 是139种吗
Lucia: Is it 139 kinds?
Alice:不知道
Alice: Don't know
Jake:我觉得不是
Jake: I don't think so
Lucia: 不是一共就那么几种吗
Lucia: Aren't there just a few kinds in total?
Jake:他应该是组
Jake: He should be forming
Alice:他说气体数量
Alice: He said the amount of gas
Jake:组了一个什么CO2
Jake: Forming some kind of CO2
Jake:是吧对
Jake: Right, yeah
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Jake:192
Jake: 192
Jake:这个数字
Jake: This number
Alice:元素
Alice: Element
Jake:可以象征全世界
Jake: Can represent the whole world
Jake:大概有192个国家
Jake: There are about 192 countries
Jake:需要参加世界第九日的活动
Jake: That need to participate in World Ninth Day events
Jake:这是是吗
Jake: Is that right?
Alice:一共
Alice: In total
Lucia: 只有192个国家
Lucia: There are only 192 countries
Lucia: 我不知道
Lucia: I don't know
Jake:得200多吧我感觉
Jake: There should be over 200, I feel
Alice:有的没资格参加吗
Alice: Are some not qualified to participate?
Alice:这意思吗
Alice: Is that what it means?
Lucia: 没加入联合国吗
Lucia: Not joined the UN?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈不知道啊
Lucia: Hahaha, I don't know
Jake:啊是吧
Jake: Ah, right
Lucia: 哈哈哈咱也不知道啊我是
Lucia: Hahaha, we don't know either, I'm
Jake:108 在许多文化中
Jake: 108, in many cultures
Jake:108是个神圣的数字
Jake: 108 is a sacred number
Jake:象征着宇宙的和谐和完整
Jake: It symbolizes the harmony and completeness of the universe
Alice:是
Alice: Yes
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay
Lucia: 啊真的吗
Lucia: Oh really?
Jake:也也代表着
Jake: It also represents
Lucia: 我刚想到的是水浒里面的好汉
Lucia: What I just thought of was the heroes in Water Margin
Jake:对就这个水浒宇宙的完整
Jake: Yes, the completeness of the Water Margin universe
Shure: 水浒宇宙 可还行
Shure: The Water Margin universe, that's something
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice:水浒宇宙
Alice: The Water Margin universe
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake:没问题吧
Jake: No problem, right?
Jake:没问题
Jake: No problem
Lucia: 没问题写万事皆可宇宙
Lucia: No problem, write "anything goes in the universe"
Jake:水浒宇宙
Jake: Water Margin universe
Lucia: 都是那两个漫画公司折腾出来的破事
Lucia: It's all just the mess those two comic companies made.
Lucia: 不过我从我从高中开始看DC和漫威
Lucia: But I've been reading DC and Marvel since high school.
Lucia: 然后一直看到现在
Lucia: And I've been reading them till now.
Lucia: 然后每天都每天都在
Lucia: And every day, every day I'm...
Lucia: 就是精神股东
Lucia: Like a spiritual shareholder.
Lucia: 和期待这两个公司破产的边缘摇摆
Lucia: And I'm always teetering on the edge of hoping those two companies go bankrupt.
Lucia: 因为我觉得你们写出来那种狗屎故事
Lucia: Because I think the stories you write are just crap.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 要不然还是别编了哈哈哈
Lucia: Maybe just stop making them up, hahaha.
Jake:还有一个
Jake: There's one more.
Jake:这个 197
Jake: This, 197.
Jake:这个数字代表1970年
Jake: This number represents the year 1970.
Jake:那一年首次庆祝的地球日
Jake: The first Earth Day was celebrated that year.
Jake:这个数字具有重要的历史和纪念意义
Jake: This number has important historical and commemorative significance.
Jake:看对不对
Jake: Let's see if it's right.
Lucia: 我估计他就是算准了
Lucia: I guess he calculated it correctly.
Lucia: 有些东西你也不能确定
Lucia: Some things you can't be sure of.
Lucia: 所以他就在这乱说
Lucia: So he's just talking nonsense.
Jake:对他就是乱说
Jake: Yeah, he's just talking nonsense.
Jake:这个确实是真的 1970年
Jake: But this is actually true, 1970.
Shure: 怎么跟大张伟那死动静似的
Shure: Why does it sound like Da Zhangwei's noise?
Shure: 把这个大屏幕打开然后
Shure: Turn on the big screen and then...
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
Shure: 想想地球日的题目
Shure: Think of a topic for Earth Day.
Jake:行啊来吧
Jake: Sure, let's do it.
Jake:谁有那什么账号
Jake: Who has that account?
Shure: 哎把那俩遥控器给我去
Shure: Hey, give me those two remote controls.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey...
Jake:遥控器是在这
Jake: The remote control is here.
Jake:所以他开了是吧
Jake: So he turned it on, right?
Lucia: 问大家132为什么是回文书
Lucia: Ask everyone why 132 is a palindrome.
Jake:嗯哦
Jake: Hmm, oh...
Alice:啊为什么呢
Alice: Ah, why is that?
Jake:问问他是吧
Jake: Ask him, right?
Lucia: 对就把这个做
Lucia: Yeah, just make this a...
Jake:我再问一下
Jake: I'll ask again.
Lucia: 不是把这个作为一个题目
Lucia: No, just make this a topic.
Jake:哈哈哈让大家乱编
Jake: Hahaha, let everyone make it up.
Lucia: 对对对我可能会被全场人打神经病
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, I might be seen as crazy by everyone.
Jake:人均GBT哈哈哈
Jake: Average GBT, hahaha
Jake:人均GBT
Jake: Average GBT
Jake:弱智娃
Jake: Dumb kid
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahaha
Jake:我们要不就弱智娃
Jake: How about we just go with dumb kid
Jake:题目里面抽几个得了哈哈哈
Jake: Let's just pull a few from the questions, haha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Haha
Lucia: 我又想起来昨天那个北京是什么
Lucia: It reminded me of yesterday, what was Beijing?
Lucia: 我说直辖市
Lucia: I said it's a municipality
Alice: 是个城市
Alice: It's a city
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 我没看到他指的那辆车
Lucia: I didn't see the car he was pointing at
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 我以为你
Lucia: I thought you
Jake:太典型了这个哈哈
Jake: This is too classic, haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 我以为你真的在正儿八经的问
Lucia: I thought you were seriously asking
Jake:哈正儿八经的
Jake: Haha, seriously asking
Lucia: 所以对
Lucia: So yeah
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahaha
Jake:问北京市
Jake: Asking about Beijing
Lucia: 然后我就没有感觉到这个问题的意义
Lucia: Then I didn't see the point of the question
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:就送来一个正确的回答
Jake: Just gave a correct answer
Lucia: 对啊这个肯定不会出错吧
Lucia: Yeah, this one definitely couldn't be wrong
Lucia: 谁知道你问的是车呢
Lucia: Who knew you were asking about the car
Jake:所以试试
Jake: So try it
Jake:吧那个车
Jake: That car
Alice: 啥我没看
Alice: What? I didn't see
Lucia: 不知道不了解
Lucia: No idea, no clue
Lucia: 就是有一个车牌子叫北京
Lucia: There's a car brand called Beijing
Lucia: 汽车厂牌
Lucia: A car manufacturer
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia: 现在是冷笑话时间了是
Lucia: Is it time for lame jokes now?
Shure: 哈哈太蠢了
Shure: Haha, that's so dumb.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What is that?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure: 哎呦我受不了了
Shure: Oh, I can't take it anymore.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 卧槽太傻逼了
Shure: Damn, that's so stupid.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 怎会如此out
Lucia: How can it be so out of touch?
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哎呦
Alice: Hahahahaha, oh my
Jake:就是弱智吧
Jake: It's just stupid.
Jake:还有什么
Jake: What else?
Jake:被门夹过的核桃还能还能补
Jake: Walnuts crushed by a door can still be
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahahaha
Jake:还能补脑
Jake: can still improve brain function.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:哈多少被蚊炸过
Jake: Haha, how many have been squashed by mosquitoes?
Lucia: 别提了，我
Lucia: Don't mention it, I
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:喝杯豆汁压压惊吧哈哈哈
Jake: Have a cup of soy milk to calm your nerves, haha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Katrina: 我们是要给AI吃什么
Katrina: What should we eat for love?
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Katrina: 没有这个已经用起来了
Katrina: No, this is already being used.
Jake:哈没有没有
Jake: Ha, no, no
Jake:这个已经用起来了
Jake: This is already being used.
Jake:就是AI里边就是有一个研究
Jake: In AI, there's a study.
Jake:就是说用弱智吧的这个数据做训练
Jake: It says using data from stupid people for training
Katrina: 嗯然后能训练出随手一点
Katrina: Yeah, and then it can train to be handy.
Jake:然后效果比别人
Jake: and the results are better than others.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哎
Jake: Hahaha hey
Jake:你这个灯是没有了
Jake: Your light is out
Katrina: 真没有了吗
Katrina: Is it really out?
Shure: 灯怎么变红了
Shure: Why did the light turn red?
Jake:啊红的
Jake: Ah, it's red
Jake:没关系啊
Jake: It's okay
Jake:要不你看一下手机对
Jake: Why don't you check your phone?
Katrina:   ：打扰一下你
Katrina: Excuse me
Katrina: 为什么这个充电宝肯定是
Katrina: Why is this power bank...
Jake:对你看一下啊这个
Jake: Yeah, take a look at this
Alice:孕妇打人算群殴吗
Alice: If a pregnant woman hits someone, is it considered a group fight?
Alice:嗯孕妇打人算群殴
Alice: Hmm, if a pregnant woman hits someone, it's a group fight
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈对
Jake: Haha, right
Jake:这个点这个很点
Jake: This point, this is very pointy
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Jake:看看看看看你的这个状态
Jake: Look, look, look at your status
Jake:他应该就是过热呀之类的
Jake: It should be overheating or something like that
Katrina: 啊他们打就算是成功了
Katrina: Ah, they hit, so it's successful
Alice:他肚子里有一个哈哈哈
Alice: There's one in her belly, hahaha
Shure: 啊过热
Shure: Ah, overheating
Jake:火热火热
Jake: It's hot, hot
Shure: 过热
Jake:嗯那你就come on
Jake: Yeah, then you just come on
Shure: 那你就come on
Shure: Then you just come on
Jake:come on
Jake: Come on
Shure: 我我come on好像呵呵
Shure: I'll come on, I guess, haha
Alice:笑死了
Alice: I'm dying of laughter
Katrina: 他不知为何他
Katrina: He doesn't know why he...
Katrina: 他给我提示说就是Quartin停止
Katrina: He gave me a prompt saying Quartin stopped
Katrina: 但是之前的这个已经没关系
Katrina: But before that, it was already fine
Jake:哦没关系再开一个吧
Jake: Oh, it's okay, just start another one
Jake:没关系没关系没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay, it's okay
Jake:早上好啊
Jake: Good morning
Jake:你这还亮着吗
Jake: Is yours still on?
Jake:你这一直不插电
Jake: You never plug it in
Jake:那当然不亮了
Jake: Of course it's not on
Jake:你不插电
Jake: You didn't plug it in.
Alice:什么哈
Alice: What, huh?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:可多了还有吃健胃消食片能吃饱吗
Jake: Can you get full by eating digestive tablets?
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 客观上来说
Katrina: Objectively speaking...
Alice:他在胃里是要占空间的吗
Alice: It does take up space in the stomach, right?
Shure: 受不了了
Shure: I can't take it.
Shure: 他怎么卡死了卧槽
Shure: How did he get stuck, damn.
Jake:就是就是
Jake: Exactly, exactly.
Jake:用这东西来训练AI的话
Jake: If you use this thing to train AI...
Jake:因为他要回答他就需要很多逻辑
Jake: Because to answer, it needs a lot of logic.
Katrina: 真的需要很多逻辑
Katrina: It really needs a lot of logic.
Katrina: 你确定吗
Katrina: Are you sure?
Jake:哈哈哈就是因为训练的时候
Jake: Hahaha, because during training...
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Jake:会给他一个人写的答案
Jake: It will give him an answer written by a person.
Jake:让人写答案
Jake: Let people write answers.
Jake:就是他会一本正经的去回答这个问题
Jake: Then it will seriously answer the question.
Jake:就是吃健胃消食片什么什么功效
Jake: Like, what are the effects of digestive tablets or whatever.
Jake:什么
Jake: What?
Alice:笑死了
Alice: This is killing me.
Jake:不孕不育会遗传吗
Jake: Can infertility be inherited?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.